what manager is asked you to divide up
the erase that you can see in a very
particular way teacher 20 on the top of
the page this way you write that for me
it's a bit of a mouthful the way you
pronounce it is wholly on the nose
that's what we in a second is a
particular kind of shape it's
constructed from and built from squares
which is why you've got this grid there
okay now let me give me an example of
how you could take those grades that
you've got there and divided up into
these kinds of shapes this is the same
kind of particular rating you have in
front of you right and you can see each
of the states here that I thought is
broken up into squares and that's
something so Napoleon you guys actually
familiar with most babies kind of
popular which is when you've got two
squares in a popular two squares right
together
does anyone know what that's gone it's
not what a holiday Domino and it's
called a domino right thank you don't
like duo
which means the suit right so you guys
are familiar with dominoes you can you
can have like some those are for
pentominoes and fine we just goes on and
on so that you can see I have a variety
of components sorry polio minutes here I
want you to help you work out we can use
right now in front of us would be them
to me of the area obviously is
polyominoes think about it this Omega
this is an easy read
he remind me if maybe there's no news
right
how did you calculate the meat what were
the two things that you did do number
one where you don't tell me we add it
all together we added every number right
and then go to then what was the second
by go ahead
now hopefully if you have a look at this
because it's a rectangular way without
counting ever seen him sweat
you can then quickly workout love the
title this right now is the first step
what's the two numbers missus sixty yeah
do you agree six by ten is about
counting okay so there are sixty squares
how many different colored shapes
different polyominoes have I divided
this particular thing about six right so
therefore you already don't total this
is sixty I think you've been divided by
six which gives you a mate of Tim as you
can see okay so you get the idea right
now this is just an example but if
particular what she goes out those
people every single poly owner that you
can see on the screen they're all
different
do you notice that I haven't repeated
any shape like I see this guy here it's
three months to I don't have another
poet like that anywhere else in the
diagram is that make sense he's the
challenge here is the real challenge so
just like you saw before right
like I didn't write I'd like you to take
these are taking the reigns and I want
you to find out these are raise these
rectangles into a whole bunch of polio
is just like you saw variety such that
no two twenty over nose are like that's
what I made you
really unique you I never repeated shake
any particular this is where we keep
that remain right I love you to divide
them up into such a way definitely use
your pencil to start with because it's
not anymore such that the mean area all
your quality of owners please okay Peter
right so how God find particular ways I
want you to divide this opportunity I
have given you um eight canisters to use
just in case something goes horribly
wrong where you do everyday things like
you like that
that's not right you're doing
translation incorrectly but I mind you
did some pencil to start with so you can
think through the victim state here's
the challenge
okay um I think at least according to
librarian I have listed these in
increasing order of difficulty at least
that's how I found it but you're welcome
to start on any of the ABC do it is not
really okay so good luck I will leave
this up here service specifically I have
any questions this shape so let me go
back
how closely
krishana a really good question which
was when I said alike what do I mean I
made in terms of the configuration of
the shape as opposed to have a look at
this piece a very young and the blue one
at the bottom right corner do you see
that do you see coming squares
I can't seven right so you call these
hepatoma notice because that's the same
like they have to go
so they're both allowed to have the same
area in fact the final three questions I
specifically want them to have the same
areas that's the heart of the challenge
does that make sense so this is an
example but it's not one questions you
have because gracious in this hope so
let me come into the kitchen so the
challenge is six units where as a mean
five units squared there's be all units
win as a mean and then I'll let you come
to the in due time every the way okay